David Jeffrey is a lawyer and former
Obama campaign adviser from join sister
David thanks a lot for coming on so
before we get to the broader questions
about where the country is going and
what we can absorb a few questions about
what happened over the weekend I've
watched all day as Americans have
defended foreign citizens who attacked
American border agents and suggested
that somehow the Americans are in the
wrong when foreigners waving foreign
flags or rocks at them how does that
work well you showed some compelling
footage and I think both sides of this
debate need to take a deep breath and
think about their positions so I agree
with you remember that we have the right
to control our border and decide who
gets in on the other side we also have
to use rule of law when we process
people who do have the right to apply
for political asylum under the laws of
our country and have the right to do
that and what while being in a peaceful
place and not under the economic that a
serious security situation that they
face in Honduras now there's a
compromise what we look for is really
tell you what the let's just address the
facts of this case just for a second if
they were applying for asylum then why
did they rush the border crossing is
that what asylum application looks like
well not all of them are probably gonna
meet the standard for asylum but would
you say that someone who waves the flag
of a foreign country is he Russia's your
border station is eligible for asylum
well I don't understand why they would
be holding their flag when they're
running from that country so that's a
good point but some of what if they rub
them well what if they try and bum-rush
the border agents doesn't that
immediately disqualify that we both
agree that they have no right to bum
rush our border and we have the right to
use force not lethal force but a
non-lethal force to prevent them from
coming across and for those who threw
rocks it was right for a Border Patrol
agents to arrest them and even to use
tear gas if that's what they needed to
do to stop them from coming with you all
the guys everyone lying about this why
why is the DNC and all the people work
for them Acosta and all the buffoons you
seen on television why are they
demanding that we not believe our eyes
that there's no Caravan they're telling
us they would never hop the border
you're a racist if you think
they're attacking us why are they lying
to us well it's not for me to explain
why what they're saying what what I want
to do is to talk about what is a
sensible solution to this a which is the
compromise that was reached in October
between the u.s. Mexico and UNHCR which
is the UN refugee agency which is these
people stay in Mexico they are given
housing as they can stay there and they
are allowed to apply for political
asylum in the US while in Mexico and
during that time they will be processed
legally and their rates will be
adjudicated via our process so if they
don't meet the standard they can't come
in and the many of them in the meantime
will likely find jobs in Mexico go home
and that's all really happens but all
the what I find so straight and look I
just want to be really clear as I have
been many times I have total sympathy
for someone who wants to come here I'm
glad to be a citizen okay and I
understand why they want to be but what
about our interests like how many people
can we absorb because no one's even
pretending this is gonna make us a
better richer country like that's a lie
and everyone knows it it's gonna make us
poorer obviously accepting a lot of poor
people when automation is making our own
jobs go away so how many people can we
accept before this country really
changes for the worse seriously it's a
serious problem I mean we have somebody
asking many different views of where
America is you paint America to be this
feeble state that can barely deal with a
couple thousand people want to be
processed I think we're still the
wealthiest strongest country in the
world is it and we also we also have
accepted many immigrants everyone here
unless you're Native American you are an
immigrant just no but you're gives a
matter of how far away you're like what
is a number so we've got 320 million
people I've got a bunch of kids I plan
to die in this country and I kind of
want to know what its gonna look like
and I want a voice in that so what can I
expect how many more people do we let in
before it's like it's enough well we're
letting in far fewer this year and last
year then but what's a good before we
should look forward but and and we have
an immigration problem which is we have
too many people here who are here
unlawfully we need to deal with that
problem but we can't completely cut off
immigration if that sensible immigration
we have to protect our border I would
not close our bumper sticker sorry I
just want to know
I want someone to tell me 50 years now
here's what America will look like I
mean no one wants in the conversation
because bad kazi's know that debate it's
nice to have that debate here but that
debate needs to take place in Congress I
don't hear on a charter pass and
immigration law that makes these
decisions sets numbers let's and it
decides let's have a real comedy we're
gonna weigh there's no one else is doing
it I want it on this show
is the only show that I co cast that
conversation and no one will engage with
me I'm engaging with you
thank you David great to see you thank
you